tonight on et canada it's big brother
canada all access meet the season 10
house guests competing to win 100 000
i'm not turning anything down nobody can
be a bigger personality than me then
[Music]
only we can take you inside the
refreshed bb can house for an exclusive
guided tour plus
season nine winner tashon carter newman
opens up about life after big brother i
can't put into words how much fun i've
had since i've left the house and
i don't want to give too much away
because i do want you to watch arisa cox
fills all the season 10 secrets this is
et canada
[Music]
tonight is the night the premiere of big
brother canada's milestone 10th season
but before the gameplay begins we're
giving you a sneak peek at what's to
come the little hell from last year's
winner to sean carter newman hey i'm so
glad you're here hey thank you sangeeta
i can't wait for season 10 and i'm so
excited to be with you for the next half
hour we've got lots of stores so let's
get started let's get started what
better place to start than inside the bb
can house we've seen it transform into a
casino super spy headquarters even a
spaceship but right now it's over to
host and executive producer erisa cox
for a look at what's new and improved
this time around
oh hey there welcome to the brand new
season 10 big brother canada house it is
glossy it is shiny it is sexy it has
everything you need to represent the
greatest game on earth let's go
[Music]
over 180 000 feet of video and audio
cable 22 kilometers of led tape we're
talking 20 000 man hours for this build
so we wanted the house to make you feel
like you were inside a game show whether
it be retro or modern and i mean come on
does anything scream more classic game
show than this wheel right here because
trust and believe we will be leaving the
house guests heads spinning
our houses really are like these living
breathing entities and this year more
than ever it was purpose built for the
twists tasks and challenges coming your
way this season like all of these
mystery doors what secrets lie behind
them
it's going to take all season for you
and the house guests to find out
now if you've ever seen big brother
canada before you know so much goes down
in the bathroom because it basically is
one of the only rooms in the house that
every single player has an excuse to be
in so i guarantee you sparks are gonna
fly right here
so this is the diary room where you
really do get to fall in love with house
guests because of course this is where
they are safe to talk about their most
intimate thoughts and their game
theories
and think back to all of your favorite
players over the years chances are they
gave really good diary room
[Music]
oh i love this one come on check out the
new hoh room
now aside from the power this room right
here is why you want to be head of
household we are really feeling our 70s
fantasy with this one
from the velvet to the shag
to the crystal to these hot hot colors
and these gorgeous sequined letters i
mean come on couldn't you picture a head
of household trying to figure out how to
take over the game or take over the
world
this house has over a hundred cameras
over a hundred microphones and a million
secrets including what's in this room
[Applause]
[Music]
well there you have it the season 10
house the game with it a game within a
game and the one last thing we wanted to
show you was this giant 32 by 16 foot
video wall behind us
something we added to just remind these
brave house guests exactly what they're
playing for
all right back to you guys
and we will be back inside the house
later in the show now tashawn you played
nah no you played
you played an incredible game but would
you change anything honestly sankita no
not a thing everything worked out for me
it's a good point good point but this
year's house guests all think that they
have what it takes to be the next winner
of big brother canada so let's find out
how some of them plan to do it
my strategy to win big brother that is a
great question my strategy is to
find my human split the house rule the
house and hopefully collect the money i
want to be the type of person who is
able to go into the competition knowing
exactly what they want out of it and
what i want out of it is to be able to
connect with a lot of people in the
house i've thought a lot about how to
win this game that said
it's season 10 they're gonna throw some
twists our way early on i want to
diminish my threat level make the other
house guests laugh and frankly just be
great to live with later in the game i
want to find the people i trust
and slit the throats of everybody who i
don't i'm just gonna treat all the house
guests like my cat i'm gonna give them
pets i'm gonna give them scratches and
i'm just gonna treat them well and feed
them great my strategy to win big
brother canada is gonna be a big social
game big flirtatious game showmance be
everyone's best friend but backstab when
i need to to be honest with you i feel
like the real strategy is to not have a
strategy because you never know what
you're gonna get into when you pop up in
that house it's a game of absolute
unpredictability so you could make all
the strategies and plans in the world um
but they may not line up so if you can
just adapt in the moment and try to make
decisions that are going to have the
fewest repercussions in the future
that's the best plan i just want to
maintain a positive mindset a strong
mindset and i always want to put god
myself and erisa cox first
anything that i do
all right i'm back with our very special
guest co-host to sean carter newman
you're doing so great usually you and i
would be sitting over there talking but
right now we're keeping our distance now
it's been almost a year since you've won
how has life been
life has changed
dramatically so what has been the
biggest change i mean the fans must be
coming to you talking to you about it
you became a celebrity
i wouldn't say celebrity but really well
known you know like i get to meet lots
of new people i'm getting to know i'm
getting to build a bunch of new
relationships and it's been so much fun
like i can't put into words how much fun
i've had since i've left the house all
right let's talk about some of the
relationships that are different when
you come outside the house
how are you with jed jed jeff's my guy
that's my vote for life we always will
be undercover brothers we still keep in
touch but i haven't seen him that much
what about that beth i haven't seen beth
at all but i still talk to her i still
always have love for beth she was one of
my best friends in the house as well and
finally braden i love braden but i
haven't seen him in a while so i'm
really curious i don't know he's all the
way out west i haven't spoken to him in
a bit either but again we had such a
great relationship in the house and i've
cherished that forever do you miss
anything about living in the house i
mean there's an experience there i mean
once you came out did you kind of say oh
i want to go back into the house no no
that must have been something you missed
about it i miss nothing about being in
the house you know what i miss the
people like the experience the people
and really getting to know people at
that intimate level is what i really
love but beyond that
i don't miss being actually physically
in there i have a little bit of ptsd
maybe oh
you know what's so great also the fact
that you won after arisa cox really
spoke up about making changes and have
representation you were the first black
winner which
means so much i mean for you to be part
of this change must be so important to
you
i think it's so important you know what
before i went on the show my mom said
you have to represent something bigger
than yourself yeah and bigger than
winning and i think in that season we're
able to to do that and establish that
and i think it was powerful for a lot of
people to see all over the country i
think it's powerful for even potential
future house guests to see people who
look like you in the house and to see
people that look like you on tv means
the world all right tisha we'll have
much more with you coming up but right
now let's continue to hear from the
season 10 house guests and find out what
kind of personalities they may or may
not get along with
i think i'm going to clash with somebody
that is very rah-rah-rah loud drama
always just in the mix of all the
problems
definitely like abrasive
people that are extremely entitled uh
rude people like a cocky stuck up rude
personality i feel like that doesn't
really mesh well with me i don't want to
say necessarily overconfident because
i'm a confident guy but somebody who
like you know really exudes that like
i'm superior the only person that i'd
clash with in the house is somebody
who's going to try to be a bigger
personality than me just to put me down
because nobody can be a bigger
personality than me
type of personality that i will clash
most with is probably
somebody that is egotistical someone
that probably likes to mansplain a lot
i definitely don't get along with people
who take life too seriously i physically
i just can't it's like why what's going
on right now like just relax and i just
take it easy so people that are walking
around super stern and in your face it's
gonna be a lot for me to deal with and i
don't like that
i hate negative people people that are
just always toxic and negative and
complaining about everything i can't
deal with them i will clash with the
type of personality that's that's fake
whenever i watch past seasons a lot of
time when somebody is going outside the
door they turn around they love you i
love you
sometimes i don't even say that to my
wife so i'm not going to say it to the
other house yes i guarantee you
[Music]
don't go away there's more big brother
canada all access after the break right
ty yes and arista cox is giving us a
tease of tonight's season premiere plus
i'm giving you my hot takes on all
things bb cans can't wait
welcome back well no one knows big
brother canada better than the people
who've played it over the last nine
seasons we've seen all kinds of game
tactics so earlier we got to sean's
expert opinion with a little something
we call ties takes
[Music]
i really think my strategy was to change
as the game changes and to be dynamic
the game is always changing your friends
are going to go home you have to
reinvent yourself when your alliance or
the dynamic in the game changes
i would say accomplished is someone who
wins throughout the season is able to
win many competitions whether they're
vetoes or hohs but the whole house knows
they're a threat but they're able to use
competitions to help circumvent that
threat you never know what the comps are
going to be i say being physically fit
may help but it looks like on my season
it didn't do much for me it was actually
my mental and my memory is what ended up
really getting me through that game
congratulations you are the final hoh
for season nine
[Music]
you have to play the game that best fits
you
and sometimes
you can be a floater just based on your
personality type and based on the other
personality types in the house i have a
lot of respect for it but
only if it's a strategy if you just
floated because
you're just hanging out
that's what i don't respect if it's a
purposeful strategy and you can
articulate that that was your strategy
then yeah i have so much respect for it
[Applause]
my advice to someone in a showmance
don't be in one ty's a very flirty guy
i just know that i catch feelings very
easily keep it as more of a flirt match
or have it appear as a flirtmats the
rest of the house guest because once
you're in a show match you're locked in
[Music]
okay so i know you're not a big fan of
show mances but it makes great
television ty it does sangeeta but not
if you want to win
[Laughter]
but you know what i guarantee sparks
would fly between some of this year's
house guests but they just don't know it
yet showmance are no man's
nomads please no no no no no no it's
either a fromance with erisa or nothing
showmance or no man
i am definitely showmance
i don't know why i looked at the camera
like that did that thing
you're locked away from society for so
long and i am a lover i wear my heart on
my sleeve and i love a good eye candy so
why not a showman i'm not gonna go
looking for it but if it's there and
she's cool let's rock i think for sure
at first i will be using a showmance as
a game move but who knows once you're in
there the heart wants what it wants
no man's for sure and married happily
married to the most wonderful uh woman
on earth but hopefully i get a bromance
i'm for sure gonna have a make out mans
maybe like a flirtmance but i'm a virgo
i don't need a relationship
showmans or nomads that's a good
question i am in a very loving healthy
relationship for the last two years now
and i don't want to change any of that
so i think for me it might be like a
best friend mass or like maybe like a
best girlfriend man like i want a sister
in the house that i get along with
that's kind of my life there will be no
mass for me i'm very happy in my
relationship right now they're always
distraction like there's never not a
time where it's a distraction and i want
to carry myself myself
i want to carry myself through myself i
think that showmance is definitely are
fun but you usually get clipped right
before the end so i think for myself i'm
going to stay away from showmances and
just try to play my game obviously i
will not be making out with people or
having sex with people or having a
relationship existing after that but
yeah going into the house i still am
going to love up on everyone even if i'm
not going to end up in a showmance
indifferent is that an answer
all right we're getting closer to the bb
can 10 premiere and to get you even more
pumped for the new season let's check
back in with erisa cox to get the scoop
hey erisa sangeeta season 10 can you
believe this yes congrats on 10 seasons
this is a huge milestone could you have
imagined getting to this point blazing
into season 10 i am so grateful i am so
humbled that this thing that we love
that we make
has been so embraced by the country and
that we're still here i know this game
inside out so how will you be
celebrating the 10th season on the show
we want to keep blazing into the future
we are always leaders in this genre so
we were like no let's make it shiny and
new and fresh but let's fill it with
easter eggs that call back to different
seasons and different twists and
different houseguests i think i have a
pretty sweet party trick
[Music]
now this show is seen as one of the best
versions of big brother in the world how
does bb can 10 raise that bar
well one thing you know about this show
is that we are
the most extra show on canadian
television we are if you can if you can
take it to 100 we'll take it to 150
that's always what we've done this is
wild this is a season that is really
shouting out the the true heart of big
brother
in that it is the greatest game on earth
what excites you the most about the new
cast
i really think we have so many things
that we have to get right we have to try
to represent so many different kinds of
people and regions and ethnicities and
backgrounds and knowledge of the game
all of those things shape the cast that
we have now if you could give the house
guest one piece of advice before
entering the house what would it be well
you know we'd like to keep the
houseguests on their toes that's one
thing you'll find that the people who
succeed in big brother canada are the
ones that are able to adapt to whatever
we are throwing at these guys and it is
a lot they can't be as good at this game
as i am
arissa big brother canada is known for
crazy calms and epic twists sometimes on
the first night what can fans expect are
there surprises
always i mean first of all we're
surrounded by doors
so many mystery doors and so many
different things are going to be behind
these doors what is this
i don't want to give too much away
because i do want you to watch because
it is going to be such a killer premiere
we are so excited
all right we're just minutes away from
the season 10 premiere of big brother
canada but first more with the new house
guests when we return
e.t canada is upgrading your weekend
with a brand new show exclusive
celebrity interviews extended features
on hollywood's hottest headlines and a
wrap-up of the week's trending topics
saturdays all global
[Music]
welcome back to big brother canada all
access we're just minutes away from an
all-new season of bb can gameplay i'm
getting nervous ty i'm getting nervous
for the house guests nervous for them
too but well let's hear from some of the
cast as they tell us why they're about
to be your new favorite house guest
besides
me
oh
this is something i haven't thought
about oh no
canada is going to root for me because i
am representing surrey bc
hello so lame oh goodness
so last year i was mistaken for the kyle
moore who was a big brother canada
season nine and uh
now i'm here so
something worked out i mean they rooted
for me before i was even a house guest
so the idea of actually being on the
house i hope that carries over canada's
gonna root for me because i'm going to
bring the perfect blend of drama
entertainment and drive to win this game
i'm willing to go out there fast up
manipulate cheat do whatever i have to
do to win the game okay i think canada's
gonna root for me because they're gonna
see that i'm genuine i'm positive i'm
somebody that they can really understand
because i'm down to earth just like
every other canadian is i'm not sure if
canada's gonna root for me you can't
assume how people are interpreting
things until you're out of the house so
i'm playing my game i'm trying to win
and i'm not thinking too much about
canada liking or disliking me i'm just a
regular smuggler girl second generation
i feel like there is a stereotypical
punjabi girl image out there in the
media so if i saw myself on the show i
feel like would make a massive impact so
i'm so honored to be able to you know
represent
[Music]
like share heart emoji absolutely but
want to really get inside the story this
is such a different character than i've
ever played
canada goes further how awesome is that
one-on-one with the biggest stars
there is nothing that i can do the
gossip and all the good stuff most
famous person who's ever slid into your
dms sean mendes live it love it canada i
love you guys and that come on amazing
ut canada we're with you weeknights on
global
et canada is back in studio for season
17 with fun celebrity interviews plus
all the details you need on trending tv
movies music and fashion weeknights on
global
thank you so much for watching big
brother canada all access and to sean
thank you for co-hosting with me this
special thank you for having me you know
what i love this game and i'm ready to
pass on the torch for season 10. oh
that's right you got to give it up well
let's leave you now with a little taste
of what's to come here's an exclusive
sneak peek of tonight's season premiere
and remember
someone's always watching
[Music]
[Applause]
hi how are you steph kyle so nice to
meet you
what is this
oh my god
did they all see this
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna yeah get out of
this room
[Music]
hello arisa
stop ignoring me
it's very
beyonce
oh canada if you can't tell i'm living
my best life